[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
[Música]
y
y mucha
en mi corazón
si pudiera
[Música]
si pudiera pasar de orilla
de plata y si pudieran y arte en papel
luego ponerle de boquilla cartonera para
mí
el color de tu cara
[Música]
nada
y qué
[Música]
a la tierra
y
[Música]
nunca más sobre mí
lo cual es una potencia y aunque me
sirva de consuelo el día
eres mi única lección mi ilusión de cada
día
pronóstico muy abierto un grupo en el
todo
si pudiera mirar tan papel
arriba poner la boquilla cartonera para
pintar
el color de tu canal moral
d
pero más fuerte
quiere dar son para tu melena cada día
más cantada
y ahora tengo las llamas
qué más
[Música]
a las llamas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
aunque no me fiaba mucho de
/ ahora vamos hasta una canción de una
persona dramática total que su vida no
tiene sentido porque ya no está ella
[Música]
cuando yo beba agua tú puedas final
bien
[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
está saliendo bien
[Música]
ah
o no
empieza ya
[Música]
como el disparo a las sienes del futuro
yo no acató no quiero volverte a ver
[Música]
fue un choque para los jazz
aplicamos las muestras
contra otra mujer
tengo otro tiempo y eso es fruto al piso
para un tenorio avispado en el amor
pero a mi edad un 13% y velorio
lleva roto el corazón
ya no me quedan ni galván mi cuerpo
y me acompaña al país
pasa del nivel de los cuentos
a viejo verde en la parranda de los
pares
me consuelo
me cautivó
[Música]
refugiado
añorando lo que fui
alemany un momento contigo
esta eternidad
[Música]
pero todo me parece extraño me sobran
años y me falta vida
dónde se habrá metido amores con
cuerpazo que cuando iba a hacer mi madre
se volvían al pasado me veo viejo entre
tanta señorita
ni la gordita pasan por alto la edad
ya no respetan ni el tiempo que uno ha
vivido como si fuera mejor vino el que
se acaban de pisar
después de tantos años sin parar
aunque se intuye el amor me pregunto no
quedan guapas como la de antes de la
siguiente para ahorrarte los injustos
me consuelo
me refugio
[Música]
añora dolor
un poco
d
[Música]
cómo
[Aplausos]
aunque esta canción se llamaba cariño
impracticable
está
es muy nueva a lo mejor no le sale bien
a él
lo que yo haga lo que a lo mejor no
el extra músico bueno
[Risas]
a
no todavía
efe
[Música]
i
y llevaron a mano
vale
[Música]
y un oponente
dada en el frente a mí tu risa esta
subida en el hoyo tú
[Música]
ah
mizoram y en todo lo demás me susurran
las canciones
al oído como tú
así lo hizo boca
donde antes siempre estaba en mi boca en
mi mano al otro lado de la mina
pero no encuentro tus besos en la olla
del pusieron mi centrífuga la lavadora
[Música]
bueno
cuando daba
los cables que pagan de un mecanismo
cariño impracticable de frenar el mundo
el sebo volverán
como cuando me quería
no lo es
[Música]
quedó vela y un mechero
como solo soy tu amigo en tu cuenta del
facebook y no puedo acariciarte por
whatsapp
cómo brillan tus ojos en el recibo de la
luz y siguiendo te por peter no te veo
caminar
[Música]
he decidido buscarte donde siempre
habían estado
en silencio entre la gente recostada en
mi costado pero tu mejor perfil
no está colgado en la red de cocina la
thermomix
y coqueteando en mi piel
y me están entrando ganas
déjala dando los cables para pagarle el
merca
y machacar y practicable de frenar el
mundo los ecos volverán a serlo
[Música]
apagando
de henares
volver a montar
[Música]
como cuando me queda
sin manolo
quedó velas de siero
mire
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]
como protocolo
porque el gran combo
un beso antes de ir a la mágica
no se separaron parecían crónicos
más
todos los problemas parecían ridículo
se vieron su rostro como algo mágico
y empezó a besarla
lo mejor cosa
tumbó en la cama
un carro su ropa
hizo que volaran
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dentro del atlántico
fácil
como una vez gravedad
[Música]
i
vivieron cada mañana
los telediarios
y dejaron de verse antes de ir al ático
se vieron su rostro parecían ridículo
no se separaron
como algo mágico
hubo protocolo
[Música]
como dos extraños
y se dieron un beso
porque eran como dónde
vieron en cada mañana como algo crónico
y no la besaba
lo mismo con xavi co
y la tumba valen la cama
me desgarraba son ropa
me hacía que volara
dentro de aquel ático buscaba el espacio
como una gráfica
[Música]
todo era un problema diario
dejaron de verse
como algo mágico
[Música]
todos los problemas
parecería muy crónicos
vieron cada mañana como algo ridículo
no se separaron porque eran cómodos
[Música]
se dieron un beso
como dos extraños
no hubo protocolos antes del galáctico y
empezar a estarlo
no me encontré un sádico
la espalda estaba
pero no fue un robo
[Música]
no no no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
con la paz
como una negra vida
[Música]
y salieron sobre otro en los telediarios
[Aplausos]
[Música]